de l'athlétisme du basket de la natation
du tennis de table ou encore de la voile
ce sont les disciplines et plus
facilement pratique est proposée au sein
du foyer le club handisport
un club né au tout début des années 80
et qui depuis n'a cessé de se développer
aujourd'hui conseiller technique du
comité régional josse la nina se
souvient de ses premières années et
surtout de cette fameuse années 2000
cette fois-là 3 martinique et du foyer
le club sans retenue en équipe de france
pour participer aux jo de sydney tu te
me promis on n'avait jamais vu ça dans
l'histoire du sport même du sport au
tout court en général puisque même dits
valides en martinique n'arrive pas à ce
stade de la compétition
je pense à ukiah tome est assez en
journée des pieuvres sarkozy il voit là
c'était vraiment un moment
historique comme on dit ça marocaine sa
marque et l'image du à dispo depuis pas
une olympienne ne se passe sans voir la
présence d'au moins un faut y aller en
équipe de france la plus médiatique est
la plus médaillée ces dernières années
et bien sûrement dit françois élie mais
au delà du haut niveau obtenu par le
club
c'est surtout son accessibilité ses
infrastructures et son accueil qui sont
ainsi mises à l'honneur par ce label on
a des cadres bien formés et qui ont su
amener la pratique à un certain niveau
et puis il ya aussi la diversité des
pratiques puisque on a parlé de
l'athlétisme qui est la vitrine de la
dispo en martinique qui affirme
connaître jusqu'en mais il ya aussi des
dix autres disciplines qui sont
pratiqués en loisirs comme le tennis de
table tir à l'arc eux et j'en passe la
natation et plus dispo aussi tous les
gros handicaps et la sarbacane la boots
yasar on en fait aussi entre loisir et
compétition le basket fauteuil a vu ses
effectifs s'étoffer et en parallèle son
niveau de jeu les pratiquants ont de 8 à
50 ans mais aucune limite n'est fixée
c'est l'une des activités les plus
attrayantes au niveau du discours que
c'est assez spectaculaire il ya de la
vitesse il ya des contacts mais tout en
sécurité
j'invite d'ailleurs tous les jeunes ou
moins jeunes qui ont
pathologie un certain type d'handicap on
peut être debout est pratiquée en
fauteuil
on peut avoir
des amputations et pratiquer un fauteuil
pour qu impose la situation de handicap
on peut quand même essayer le basket
tout et c'est un sport que j'apprécie
énormément avec ses deux étoiles le foia
le club se distingue d'entrée parmi les
clubs français ayant permis au
handisport de se développer
une distinction qui le fait rentrer dans
le cercle fermé des 32 clubs français
les plus actifs